I just woke up and I'm at my boyfriend's house
and he's asleep in the other room
but I wanna answer you
my relationship with my children changed after leaving my marriage
because I no longer had
like you say
this partner that I needed to tend to
like whenever we got in an argument
and it was all the time
it's this cycle of abuse
this toxic cycle
so you know we have the big blow up argument
and then it's gonna take days to sort that out
the feelings and everything
and in those days
I'm not really gonna be present with my children
because I'm so distracted at the hurt and pain
and confusion of what's going on in my relationship
so you know I'm spending my days kind of pushing my kids away like hey
yeah yeah yeah
can you go do something else
can you do this
can you do that
cause I'm trying to like
hide from them
and so you know
I'm tryna hide my feelings from them
I'm tryna hide what's going on from them
cause you know
you don't wanna fight in front of the kids
so there's just like
the whole relationship with the kids is very superficial
cause I'm hiding so much from them
so the minute I left
I had no choice but to be authentic and vulnerable in front of them
there was no longer anything to hide behind
I no longer had this
relationship that I was running behind closed doors to argue about
I now had to like
just be there and be present with my kids
and it fucking paid off
like I know when you're trying to hide arguing from the kids you kind of
you also hide your emotions
cause you don't wanna be like
oh I'm crying cause Mommy and daddy got in an argument
so you're just like
you know constantly hiding and lying everything from your children
so there's no way you're gonna have that deep of a relationship
they can feel that
you know I don't
I don't know
you know and so
being able to be completely honest and vulnerable with my kids and
you know they no longer could see me as this super mom
I was now a total human
they could see me cry
they saw my weak moments
they saw me when I'm like
I don't know
I don't know what we're gonna do
but we're gonna figure it out
so I think they have been able to see also how much I love them
to what links I will actually go to to support them
to be there for them
to give them not just what they need
but make it happy and fun
so also like
even the mundane moments in our house are no longer eggshell
scattered all over the floor
just our regular average shit in our house
nothing special
just that is healing and nice
because we're not waiting for someone to come yell at us
or tell us what we're doing wrong or you know so
yeah literally being in a shitty relationship
is going to keep a separation between you and your children
and when you finally make the choice to leave and decide well
I have these children that really need me
and I'm gonna put them first and put myself first
the relationship is literally what I dreamed of
so hope that helps